[Music]
making a robot a part of our family has
been one of the biggest challenges I've
faced hello Joanna
great to see you it's like raising a
human infant except not at all
my name is Joanna Stern and geebo has
been a member of our family for about a
month and it's been a pretty rough month
it began as a pretty simple gadget
review Jibo had been getting a lot of
attention because unlike faceless
talking speakers like the Amazon echo he
looks like an adorable character out of
wall-e
the little guy has a 5-inch touchscreen
for a face
two cameras four eyes six microphones
for ears and a personality why was the
robot angry because someone kept pushing
his buttons I I think he's as funny as
Jerry Seinfeld's that's my opinion he
can't work but he can't walk come on yes
so there's there's a lot he can't do hey
G boo play some music music is something
I can't do yet I can't set reminders
just yet I can't show videos I can't
keep a personal calendar yet I was
expecting way more for $900 sorry did I
not mention that
Jibo can do some things Thomas Jefferson
is the third President of the United
States the forecast for tomorrow shows
Sun with a high of 51 and a low of 46
ten minutes it is honestly I could win
the Powerball tomorrow and my wife still
would not let me adopt Gebo one day I
came home and I found geebo in the
corner with his cord wrapped around his
head the next day he was hidden in the
dryer another day the trash it's his
eyes or cameras I programmed Gebo to
recognize family members by name it's
amazing at first and then it starts to
feel like you're being watched all the
time hey Joanna fancy seeing you here
there's something I can happy the
company says you can always put Gebo to
sleep and that everything Gebo sees is
never saved by geebo let alone upload it
to the cloud
the company says gee bows like a child
right now in early stages of development
the thing is I already have a five month
old son who's probably ji Bo's biggest
fan my son has no idea what a G bo is
and every time I see them interacting I
get this feeling like this is the world
he's gonna grow up in a world where
robots are our co-workers and companions
for now though No